ho ho ho ho Mary Advent it's not
Christmas yet okay but we are getting
ready for Christmas and we are preparing
for Christmas by watching a bunch of
woke Christmas tick tocks take it away
here are some Christmas traditions that
we borrowed from pagans and by borrowed
I mean stole and then condemned and then
rebranded number one Santa Claus uh
Santa Claus is actually an Old Norse
Pagan god named Odin and Odin had a long
white beard and he was old and he rode
around through the sky on an
eight-legged horse delivering presents
to people we put a buzzer Santa Claus
also known as Jolly Old Saint Nick is
not a pagan god named Odin a Santa Claus
is a saint named Nicholas that's why we
call him Saint Nicholas and he was said
to have given presents to little kids
and what he was also known for was
according to Legend slapping the Horizon
Arc areas at the Council of nicaea the
story probably apocryphal but legends
can tell us a lot about reality as well
it helps you when when you're talking to
people I said we're going to debunk
Christianity did you know did you know
that there's a similarity between this
thing that happened in the gospels and
some myth therefore the gospels are fake
and it's all just a repackaging of a
pagan myth no no Christianity is
mythical in the sense that it partakes
of types it partakes of grand narrative
it happens to be however the true myth
it is a myth that actually happened yes
it is mythical for a man to die
and then rise from the dead that's a
theme in myth it also literally happened
in Christianity so just because
something is mythical does not mean that
it can't be true number two the 12 Days
of Christmas or the concept of Christmas
in general this comes from Yule or
winter solstice which is a 12-day pig in
Winter holidays no put a pause there
that's just so fake you are fake news
they bring up all these different pagans
feasts many of which started after
Christmas by the way the one they
usually go back to is Soul Invictus but
there are others she mentions you all
but they're Soul Invictus there's
mithras there's saturnalia they're all
these feasts people will say well the
Christmas holiday was celebrated by the
Christians as a way to lure the pagans
who were celebrating Soul Invictus over
to celebrate their new holiday but
that's not true the earliest evidence we
have of Christmas is the chronography of
354 that's the earliest textual evidence
we have of this on a calendar but it's
also the earliest textual evidence we
have of the Feast of Soul Invictus so in
all likelihood the
Feast of Soul Invictus was actually made
by the pagans as a response to
Christianity the bishop hippolytus of
Rome explains why Christmas is
celebrated on the 25th and it has
nothing to do with some stupid Pagan
Feast it's because Christians believed
that a Divine life is perfect so it's
exactly the a certain number of years
Christ lived exactly for 33 years and
the early Christians understood the
conception of Christ to have occurred on
Good Friday which is the day that he
died when you've got the dating of the
conception of Christ to Good Friday then
you fast forward nine months later you
get December 25th and if that coincides
even roughly with certain Pagan feasts
sure there there might be some mythical
or Pagan celebrations there as well but
Christianity is the true myth it's not
it's not just a baptizing of certain
Pagan Traditions it's a thing that
really happened number three kissing
underneath a mistletoe this plant is
really sacred in a lot of pagan rituals
for Romans it honored the God Saturn and
to appease Saturn they would have for
utility rituals underneath the mistletoe
in terms of mistletoe I don't really I
don't know maybe I don't know I Like
This Woman's wrong about everything else
so she's probably wrong about that but
maybe yeah it could be number four the
Yule star in which each point represents
one of the five different elements
pagans used to put this on top of their
Yule trees and lo and behold we now put
stars on top of our Christmas trees and
we have the audacity to call the
pentagram satanic put a pause there
what does the star represent at
Christmas time uh symbol of the occult
and the devil or the star that announced
Christmas the symbol probably most
associated with Christmas itself I think
it'll probably be the latter number five
hanging ornaments on trees each of these
ornaments represented a God Like Saturn
or even a family's personal Patron
scenes number six decking the halls
wreaths Christmas trees Hagans would put
these up so that they would have some
life and some Greenery during the
otherwise super cold and lifeless winter
sure yeah that's true I mean the image I
was sitting out the other night in my
Courtyard and I was looking at the dead
trees outside and my Christmas tree on
the inside with the fire going and the
lights on and everything and I thought
wow what a beautiful symbol of the
Incarnation what a beautiful symbol of
Christmas we are living in this world
that has been marked by sin and death
and things die and we will die too that
sucks and then you then yeah but then
you look inside and you say wait there
is hope
there actually is Hope and there is life
and there can be life Everlasting like
with an evergreen tree I mean this is
even getting back to her point about the
star
forget the star that announces the birth
of Christ
is an astrological symbol plenty of
pagans and occult sort of people looked
up to the stars for signs but because
God is the god of the heavens and the
Earth he's the god of everything he
takes that astrological sign and it
brings these Magi these non-christians
non-jews over to see the true King Jesus
Christ keep going seven Christmas
caroling Pagan eight eggnog
singing is Pagan now the pagans get a
monopoly on singing I don't know maybe
nine you will log obviously Pagan and
number 10 my favorite December 25th
being Jesus's birthday it was celebrated
as this
which means the birth of the invincibles
there she is dedicated to Mitra or the
Roman Soul until it was stolen by Pope
Julius the first and made into Jesus's
birthday so the birth of the Invincible
Sun became the birth of the Invincible
son so again as I mentioned earlier
that's just completely fake there's no
evidence of that whatsoever that is
[ __ ] I would defy that woman to show
me the evidence that the Feast of the
unconquered son ever existed that there
was ever attested to before the the
celebrations of Christmas she cannot
find it that that does not exist no but
furthermore to go to go back to what she
was saying eggnog Pagan cake Pagan Pagan
uh no I don't think so
I don't think you get to claim Dairy
alcohol and sweets is Pagan if those
things are pagan then I guess
everything's Pagan he's Pagan he's Hagen
you're Pagan I'm Pagan are there any
others pagans I should know about meow
with Christmas right around the corner
many of us will be traveling to see our
families and loved ones soon you may
find yourself away from home more often
than not that is why I've teamed up with
a ring with ring security products you
can rest easy knowing that your home and
family are safe when you are not there
the ring doorbell notifies you when
guests or packages arrive Rings indoor
cameras let you keep an eye on kids and
pets while you're away ring alarm will
alert you of any motion detection while
the house is empty plus if you add smart
lighting around your home you can turn
lights on or off while you're away
Ring's home security products don't just
help keep your home and family safe they
make perfect gifts for everyone on your
list head on over right now to ring.com
collections slash offers to help find
out how you can live less stressed this
season with a ring product that is right
for you I love ring not only have I
gotten ring myself but I have given ring
out as housewarming presents to loved
ones you should too makes a great great
Christmas present head on over to
ring.com
collections slash offers did you know
that the song Jingle Bells was racist it
was written by a rebellious composer who
supported the Confederacy and performed
the song in blackface the songwriter
James Lord Peter Paul is there we just
want to put a pause before we get into
whatever nonsense he's saying about
Jingle Bells
black face is not racist
it probably got me in trouble with Media
Matters for saying that it's not racist
blackface itself the minstrel tradition
is not racist some of the most popular
performers in Minstrel shows of the sort
of blackface type of theater were black
men themselves the creators of some of
these characters I think of the the
character Aunt Jemima was created by a
comedian a Minstrel comedian Billy
cursands who was a black guy to say that
all this stuff is racist is to erase
much of the American theatrical
tradition oh please God what they would
say is everyone in all of history up
until this present moment every and
everyone living today except for me is a
racist because by racist they just mean
bad we're better than you and we know it
and everything other than them is bad so
that's that's that's what they're
insinuating okay keep going the
songwriter James Laura Pierpont is the
uncle of JP Morgan you know one of the
richest man in America's history while
his father and brother took fiery stands
against slavery per Pont became the
staunch supporter of the Confederacy
Jingle Bell was not always its original
name one horse open sleigh was the name
that the composer gave to it where did
he get the idea from the song you ask
although we sing this song during
Christmas it was not intended to be a
Christmas song some historical accounts
report that the tune was first performed
for Thanksgiving service at his church
these performances were performed in
blackface but what is a jingle bell a
jingle bell was a device that was put on
the neck of slaves who were the most
common to run away during the holiday
season seeing that it was locked with
bells at the end of it it would jingle
as they ran away and give away their
location so this holiday season be sure
you know your historical facts before
you sing a song I'll be doing more of
these during the month of December so
look I I'm curious my interest is peaked
here if he wanted to make that
persuasive he he probably would have
read the alleged original lyrics to the
song right because if you say okay
actually Jingle Bells
are not just Jingle Bells we all know
what jingle bells are but these Jingle
Bells referred to in the song There are
some secret kind of other jingle bells
and there are these super secret racist
ones that you've never heard of before
but they're that's really what he's
referring to you say okay what were the
lyrics because the lyrics now are jingle
bells jingle bells jingle all the way oh
what fun it is to ride in a one-horse
open sleigh the bells obviously aren't
referring to a slave running away on his
feet it's referring to the sleigh if his
argument is well no the song Jingle
Bells actually was a totally different
song okay what were the lyrics
I doubt that he could tell me what those
lyrics are because I suspect his thesis
is
somewhat historically dubious okay keep
going I Don't Wanna Live for Christmas
there is just here we go again oh hey
buddy can you believe it's already
Christmas time again yeah about that can
we dial back some of that Christmas crap
this year and maybe share the season
share with who me you're all about
celebrating a Jewish kid anyway Santa's
Jewish no
so you lie
the lion gets you on
you with a kid on the naughty list would
say you mean you're not the only holiday
thank you everyone always forgets that
easy does it Kwanzaa I got this of
course you do I mean think about it
seven days belonged to him eight
belonged to me and 12 to me oh my God
what does God have to do with this
everything you stupid secular
I half love this video because I do love
that the Hanukkah guy is attacking the
Christmas guy for not knowing anything
about Christmas but if his argument is
that Hanukkah is on the same par as
Christmas that's just ridiculous
Christmas is celebrated by 96 of
Americans Christmas is a major christian
holiday one of the most important
Christian holidays Hanukkah is
celebrated by about two percent of
Americans but even studies say okay well
just because it's a small number of
people who celebrate it doesn't mean
it's not important except it's actually
not that important because it's not a
major Jewish feast it's a minor Jewish
feast it would be like celebrating
Saints Day you know Saint Joseph the
feast of Saint Joseph I love Saint
Joseph it's great I'd love to celebrate
the Feast of Saint Joseph what is it
March 19th but it's not on the same par
as Christmas or Easter okay likewise
Hanukkah is not in the same part for
Jews as Passover let's say Sukkot Yom
Kippur something like that and then
Kwanza is a socialist contrivance it was
made up in the 1960s and it was made up
by Looney Tune socialist at Cal State
Long Beach I ended up getting arrested
for torturing and imprisoning women
falsely imprisoning them you like hit
them on the head with a toaster put
soldering irons in their mouth all sorts
of terrible things but it's not
celebrated by really anybody it's
celebrated by I think 0.2 percent of
Americans
totally made up anyway but I did like it
was kind of funny in the video when when
the Hanukkah guys like hey hold on
Kwan's all right we don't need to hear
from you right now okay let's let's
let's be real because it's Hanukkah is
way more legit than Kwanzaa happy
chanuka the equivalence that is made
between Christmas Hanukkah and Kwanzaa
is not about giving Hanukkah and Kwanzaa
their due it's just about attacking
Christmas it's just about tearing down
the only actual major Feast of the Year
okay and one that is so so important to
American culture as well that's why we
need to take the war on Christmas
seriously the libs always make fun of us
for this for for getting weirded out
when they refuse to utter the word
Christmas they're so it's the holiday
that must not be named
happy
holidays what what are the holidays
um
Hanukkah do you celebrate Hanukkah no do
you know anything about Hanukkah no do
you do you think that Hanukkah is a
major Feast you don't know but no what's
the other holiday
it's just Christmas you just don't want
to say it because the culture is turning
ever more against Christians we can say
it it's okay well I won't say yet
because it's not Christmas yet I'll say
happy Advent but when it's Christmas
they will say Merry Christmas
[Music]